And quickly before we get started, if you are
new here every single week we make new lessons
like this one so that you can understand
fast speaking natives. Without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles. So don't miss a single new
one hit that Subscribe button
and the Bell down below now.
You know most learners tell me that they can
understand English pretty well but when it
comes to speaking it's really challenging
because they just have not had that many
opportunities to practice.
Is this the case for you?
Well, what if I told you that you could speak
English right now at the touch of a button?
You can with the RealLife English App! So why
not download it now for FREE and you can have a
conversation with another person in another part
of the World maybe about your favorite songs.
You can find that by clicking up
here or down the description below,
or simply search for RealLife
English in your favorite app store.
So there you have it: 10 Great
English Songs for Your Fluency.
And if you enjoyed today's lesson then
you might want to check out some of these
full lessons that we have with some of
the artists that we looked at today.
We have some with Ed Sheeran, with Anita,
with Harry Styles and with Taylor Swift.
So you can find all those linked down
the description below or check out
our last Top 10 Songs to Learn English
with. Let's check out a clip from that!